le moment du grand frisson d'antenne de
midi est venu je vous l'annoncé en ce
début d'édition patrick esther à
l'initiative avec la collaboration de
jean yves casgha celui qui préside aux
destinées du boulevard de l'étrange sur
france inter et bien patrick esther est
allé à la rencontre d'un fantôme dans le
bourbonnais
voici ce qu'il nous en rapporte aux fous
je ne savais pas exactement pourquoi
j'avais accepté de faire ses 382 km
depuis paris
[Musique]
être simplement pour ne pas décevoir un
ami fanatique de fantômes qui pensait en
matière en ici nous convaincre du bien
fondé de sa théorie
[Musique]
ainsi donc moi le cartésien le
rationaliste j'arrivais par une belle
après midi d'août devant les tours du
chapeau devos dans le bourbonnais
[Musique]
inutile
je n'eus pas même le temps de jeter un
regard sur cette forteresse féodale déjà
un home run à marans con je reconnus en
lui un célèbre médium surveillants oui
alors qu'est ce que vous avez vu ici
âgées dernière avant l'année dernière
j'ai vu une forme fantomatique qui se
déplaçaient entre les deux tours que
vous voyez là entre la tour de l'horloge
et le tournant coiffer on a eu
l'impression qu'elle sortait de
n'oublier tine oubliettes dans la cour
et ça s'est passé à minuit exactement
et alors l'apparition est d'abord s'est
présenté sous une forme assez nébuleuses
et après la plus consistante à l'aide à
y aurait pu être perçu par plusieurs
personnes qui étaient présentes pour
vous un fantôme
c'est ce qu'on appelle un fantôme ça a
d'ailleurs été photographié pour la
première fois on a pu tirer des clichés
qui ont été contrôlés qui ont expertisé
il avait là les clichés je les ai oui on
peut les voir je pourrais vous les
montrez bien sûr alors comment vous
expliquez ça vous ben on a du mal à
l'expliquer parce que l'enfant
cette photo est expertisé vous en doutez
bien en coupe pareille
il a fallu l'expertisé s'était plusieurs
fois vérifié ben pourquoi que c'est une
manifestation d'un défunt pour la bonne
raison que si on l'appelait par son
nombre s'appelle du cilss et une femme
entre le coeur l'histoire de lucie à
l'histoire de lucie je préfère me
voulait laisser raconter par le baron
qui a connaît mieux que moi
il vous la rencontre avec moult détails
mais ce qu'on sait que c'est une femme
qui était assassiné qui a été jeté dans
les oubliettes
je décide donc de partir à la recherche
de l'uci à mon tour jallet hanter les
escaliers les cul de basse-fosse les
couloirs les corridors les galeries
mâchicoulis je tombé par hasard sur le
maître des lieux
c'est à gori de la tour vous l'avez
croisé souvent lucie 30 de temps quand
je sais pas trop fatigués quand je veux
quand même de mon château se rend compte
aussi à quoi il ressemble des
commencements
ici on ne connaît pas bien ce sujet on
voit une lumière avec quelquefois on
paie bien bien se rendre compte que ce
sont des coutures visages sont de
certains prêtres qui mènent et notamment
s'ils ne croyez plus créatives dominer
la première fois que vous l'avez vu si
vous me la fait pas bien parce que
c'était tellement longtemps
je sais vous avez conservé toute ma vie
ce serait très bien quels outils
existent et je me prépare je me fends
voir aussi je pense qu'elle fera
connaître à tous depuis toujours
ainsi donc le baron avait succombé au
charme de l'uci exactement comme il y a
quatre siècles le seigneur dit de
daillon cire de vous'
lucie était né dans une famille noble
mais pauvre
à 18 ans en pleine beauté elle entre au
service de les pousses du seigneur
jacques une de lafayette
si le barreau couvre lucide cadeau sa
femme jalouse lui voue une haine
farouche
héguy de daillon part à siéger une
forteresse huguenote c'est alors que le
droit de haute et basse justice est
transféré à jacqueline de la faille est
sa première mesure jeter la belle lui
sied aux oubliettes où elle meurt de
faim
la nuit de sa mort des paysans vous un
fantôme déambuler entre les créneaux de
la tour une chouette qui venait tous les
jours volé à proximité vient mourir
dans la cour du château l'horloge
s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
depuis presque chaque nuit son fantôme
viendrai hanter cette salle
c'est ici que certains disent l'avoir vu
et même photographier dans cette salle
des pendus un nom hérité de 1789
lorsque pendant la révolution les
sans-culottes passèrent des cordes sur
ces poutres pour pendre les seigneurs
des lieux
lucie m'avait-on dit se déplacer en
silence le nom de ce couloir sur ce
chemin de ronde où autrefois avec amour
elle attendait son seigneur
[Musique]
mais j'ai connu la famille ancienne ouah
ainsi l ancien et les anciens
propriétaires ne parlait jamais du
fantôme monsieur jamais j'ai entendu par
des mois les pages marge travail de la
terre georges mandel est un riche avec
mes vaches
peut-être qu'il y en avait qui voyez
mange jamais moi je suis allé au château
souvent mais jamais j avais eu j'aurais
peut-être pas su ce que c'était un
fantôme est ce que vous y croyez aux
fantômes personne peut joie je crois pas
aux fantômes dans ce village d'une
quarantaine dames on reste très très
prudents
bonjour bonjour j
vous êtes forcément grand toutes les
affaires vous y croyez vous un fantôme
non à partir du moment où j'ai rien vu
je crois pas tellement hassan vous
pensez qu'il ya des gens qui peuvent
voir les fantômes et les autres qui les
voient pas je crois que oui et vous
faites partie de ceux qui ne votent pas
et dans le pays il ya des gens qui l'ont
déjà vu venir je crois pas vraiment que
quelqu'un puisse dire qu'ils aient vu
ils ont peut-être espérer le voit
peut-être et menaces envers vous allez
voir peut-être aussi y en a qu'on
passait la nuit comme ça à l'unité c'est
pas tellement je ne crois pas non plus
pourquoi ou 500 pas vanter parce qu'ils
avaient rien dit à la nuit tombée
une équipe de scientifiques arrivent au
château certains d'entre eux désirent
rester anonyme la science officielle est
très discrète avec ces phénomènes
pourtant cette fois l'observation va
s'appuyer sur des moyens objectifs
d'abord on va faire un ensemble de
mesures physiques alors on va voir déjà
s'il ya des paramètres physiques bull ne
bouge pas j'ai apporté des animaux de
laboratoire on va voir ce soit
impressionné ou pas c'est très
improbable mais on ne sait jamais hein
et puis on va essayer d'avoir une
occlusion d'après ce qu'on a vu et puis
surtout d'après ce que les phénomènes de
ce que les appareils de physique au vent
enregistrées
d'après ce que j'ai pas eu photo
enregistrée ou pas et puis je sais pas
si on pourra conclure non pas peut-être
sur un passe comme ça on sait qu'on
analyse de la ionisation de l'air
analyse fine des ondes radioélectriques
enregistrement des sources lumineuses
enregistrement des ondes sonores grâce à
des micros disséminés un peu partout
dans le château celui-ci se promènent
par ici aucune chance pour elle de
passer inaperçu
[Musique]
en même temps que l'obscurité
l'angoissent s'installe lui si la dame
blanche va t elle venir
et si les fantômes existait vraiment le
doute me submerge la raison chancellent
les peurs ancestrales sont là bien
enfoui en moi même des peurs qui
ressurgissent dans le noir
j'ai peur que ni la science ni le
progrès ne peuvent effacer totalement
dans le donjon une chouette eu lieu et
si c'était le fantôme du lâche m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
mais l'ennui est passé un nouveau jour
se lève
l'uci n'est pas venu elle ne viendra pas
les nuits suivantes les fantômes n'aime
pas la science
[Musique]
pourtant au fond de moi finalement c'est
la déception
pourquoi vouloir à tout prix tuer la
légende pourquoi ne pas la laisser à
ceux qui en ont besoin pour vivre
vous avez aussi cette fois les ventes
rien fait de bien ou pas
[Musique]